i have a problem with productivity
it all begins with a very simple idea
that more of a good thing
is better productivity guru productivity
productivity equals productivity apps
how i stay productive extremely
productive toxic relationship with
productivity
so we try to be faster more efficient
less lazy
but like everything the further you go
down that rabbit hole
the less innocent things become my
channel is
tiny but i'm still contributing to this
online world of youtube
productivity and even though in my head
i'm very very clear
on my issues with it this is not
something i have necessarily discussed
on this channel before
so today here it goes these are all of
my issues
with youtube productivity firstly it
uses universal measures
for when to wake up for how much work to
do in a day for the fact that everyone
can afford a full-time job and a few
side hustles it has little to no regard
for different people's attention spans
for the fact that some people may be
parents
for the fact that some people may not
earn as much money or for the fact that
people may have different stress levels
or even learning disabilities very often
what is not seen is that these very
productive and successful people online
actually have huge teams in the
background which are helping them with
this workload
they might even have people cooking for
them or taking care of their kids or
just money to afford crazy holidays to
decompress from this crazy productive
time
so things are not as simple as they seem
online and these universal measures of
you can do it too are probably not
true next i feel like productivity makes
you respect yourself conditionally
so only if you do as much work as you
plan to do in that certain day or in
that certain hour or in that certain
week or month
only then can you feel good about
yourself you're probably going to end up
on one or more nights going to bed
feeling angry at yourself
feeling displeased with yourself and not
feeling at peace unless you complete
these quotas that you've set up in your
mind and this is probably not a good
long-term relationship to have next
effect productivity kind of puts you in
a bit of a parental role with yourself
where you're talking down to yourself
you're not listening to your excuses and
you're trying to
you know know what is best and make
yourself do things all the time while
ignoring your needs to do something else
or to do nothing at all and i feel like
this is not a good
long-term relationship to have sometimes
there are real reasons that you don't
want to do something and perhaps
listening
to yourself or your body when you just
don't feel like working is a good thing
maybe you need a break maybe you need to
socialize maybe you need to help other
people or feel valuable in a community
or society which is something that
productivity doesn't focus too much on
and i feel like it is a great loss in
the long term to be this kind of abusive
parent
to yourself next i feel as though it
might make one thing that if they're
following these formulas which are so
honestly given to you online that you
should achieve what other people have
achieved although most decent people who
are talking about productivity are not
guaranteeing this i feel as though over
the long term it may be something that
you feel
as in i'm trying to do the exact same
things why am i not getting the same
results
and it has little regard to things such
as luck or how much money these people
have before they started doing these
things or what emotional state they have
been
or what is their mental health like or
how they look for example i feel as
though these things don't play very
often into the productivity equation
online liver can leave me as a consumer
sometimes feeling as though i
must be doing something wrong i am
eternally dissatisfied with my results
in fact just being productive and
adapting these tips will get you nowhere
if you're not headed in the right
direction i love the phrase of if your
ladder is up against the wrong wall
you'll just get to the wrong place
faster
for a lot of people who have gotten
lucky and successful going in the right
direction is just as important as the
productivity tips that they have used to
get there
so if you're just using these tips but
you're going in the whole opposite
direction
you're probably not going to get to the
same results and this is not something
that is generally discussed next i feel
as though it puts you at competition
with yourself at best and with the world
at
worst you're always competing to be
better than you were last month or last
year and also quite often to be better
than everyone else around you
and although there's nothing wrong with
a bit of healthy competition i feel like
productivity relies on it
quite a lot because you need to see
improvement and do things better
and if you want to see that you've used
the productivity tips you surely now
must be faster than you were yesterday
so i feel as though this constant strive
for more and more and more is probably
not the healthiest way to live your life
next i feel like
productivity generally makes you selfish
and this is because it is just focused
internally on the person
so what did i do today how did this
impact myself how do i feel about what i
did
it doesn't really have to do a lot with
other people around me
and very often being very productive
just makes the people who care the most
about you and around you
feel worse because they're not seeing as
much of you and you're just so
self-involved in whatever you are doing
and of course there's nothing wrong with
doing what you want to do and being on
your own
i just feel like this level of
selfishness is probably something that
needs to be counter balanced with other
things which are not necessarily
discussed as much in the productivity
realm next i feel quite strongly about
this productivity is mostly focused on
the results
so how do you get more results for less
time how to get the same results for
less time
how do you get more and more and more of
everything rather than what are the
actual things that you are
achieving and how much are you enjoying
the process i feel as though enjoying
the process
is very cheesy but it's also super super
important in the extreme end in the
realm of productivity
pain can be a good thing or even a badge
of honor as in the less you sleep the
less you've talked to your family the
less you
spend doing nothing so basically the
less you respect yourself the better off
you are
i just find this to be extremely
extremely toxic so yes at the end of the
day of course i will continue making
productivity content because i
absolutely love it
i just want to say that i also feel very
strongly against it in more than one way
and in my personal life i do try to
counter balance it as much as possible
and this is something that perhaps i
will try to incorporate in my videos a
bit more
yes if you want to have a browse of my
current productivity content please feel
free to look around
otherwise thank you so much for watching
i hope you have a wonderful rest of your
day be kind yourself and others and
don't believe everything you think
thanks
[Music]
bye